-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated writer
and comedian you know
from "Saturday Night Live,"
where he serves
as co-head writer
and co-anchor of
"Weekend Update."
Here's my conversation
with Michael Che.
Michael, I cannot tell you
how happy I am to see you.
You're in Manhattan right now.
How is it?
-It's wild, man.
I'm so tired, too, by the way,
because I don't --
I didn't even sleep at all.
-You grew up in New York.
And have you ever --
Have you ever felt this way
about the city you call home?
-No. You know what's so crazy?
Is that, like --
I remember I went to Egypt
like a long time ago.
It was like 2012 or so.
And I was so excited
because I had never left
the country before.
And it was like, "They want you
to do some shows.
Would you do some shows
in Egypt?"
And I was like, "Absolutely.
I would love to go to Egypt."
And long story short,
when I got to Egypt,
I was so excited to be there,
and everybody was so happy
that I was there,
and they were like,
"We didn't think you'd come.
Everybody said no."
And I was like, "What do
you mean everybody said no?"
And they're like, "Well,
because we just had a revolution
and nobody wanted to fly here."
And I had no idea
that they just had a revolution.
So I flew over to Egypt
during a revolution,
not knowing
there was a revolution.
And learning
about that revolution,
it's eerily similar
seeing what's happening now
to what
they were describing then,
which is kind of scary
and crazy surreal.
-Your last stand-up special,
you talked a lot about race.
You talked a lot about
the black community's
relationship with police.
And this then seems to be a clip
that resurfaces every time
something like this happens.
-Yeah. It's kind of --
It's almost bittersweet
because I'm happy
that people like the clip,
but it's also kind of a bummer
that it's still relevant.
I wish it wasn't, you know?
It's almost like --
I feel like the guy
who wrote "Amazing Grace."
Like, every time --
You're happy you hear the song,
but every time you hear it,
you're like,
"Oh, no, what happened?"
Because no one plays it
for a good occasion.
-I wonder -- Yeah, I never
thought of it that way.
I wonder when he wrote it
if he thought,
"Well, this will be -- We'll
hear this a couple of times."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and it's never
for a good thing.
No one's ever like,
"You know what I want to hear?
'Amazing Grace.'"
-Will you just tell us sort of
the seed of the stand-up bit
that sort of keeps coming back?
-It was this black --
I don't remember. It's a bit.
It's a Black Lives Matter bit
of just about --
I mean, the sentiment being --
I think what people kind of
connect with is that
it's just saying
that we're just asking
to matter,
and somehow
that becomes a challenge
or somehow that becomes
unreasonable to some people.
And the absurdity of not being
able to give us that much,
you know, is really all it is.
-And, I mean, that's, of course,
speaking to people
who really like to stress
whenever they hear
"Black Lives Matter"
that all lives matter.
-Yeah.
-It must be frustrating.
And it must be frustrating
that people stand in the way,
it seems like, of the idea
of even equal rights.
-It's almost like what --
[Groans] I don't know.
It's kind of hard to --
After a while, you stop --
Um...
you stop worrying about why they
don't want to give it to you
and you get to the point
where you just demand it.
And I think that's
what we're seeing now.
We've been asking for so long
that people are at a point
where they don't want
to ask anymore,
and that's kind of the reality,
and it's sad.
-This must be an
incredibly hard time for you
for a number of reasons,
but you have a brother
who's a detective in the New
York City Police Department.
Do you talk to him
through times like this?
-No, I don't really like to talk
to him about stuff like this.
[ Laughs ] Well, I'll make
fun of him in hindsight.
But, you know,
I can only imagine
what it must be like for him
to grow up the way we grew up
and also have to do his job
with people who police
the way, you know, some of these
guys police, so...
-You have another --
Am I correct?
You have another brother
who's a retired police...
-I have two brothers
who are cops.
I have four brothers
and two sisters.
Two of them are NYPD.
Listen. My mother wasn't
raising rocket scientists.
We're cops and comedians
and barbers.
[ Laughs ]
But, yeah, you know, I mean,
they get it, you know?
Like, they're from where
we're from, but, you know,
it's still -- I don't know.
It's a weird thing.
I bet -- I bet --
I don't think I've ever
dialed 911 in my life.
-Just because you don't think
that they'll be helpful
or that you can't imagine
that the outcome will improve?
-Because I have a feeling
that they're not for me,
and it's a really sad,
unfortunate thing
that you don't realize
until you come across people
who don't feel that way.
Does that make sense?
-It certainly does.
You know, listening to people
explain why they're
in the street protesting,
it does seem like,
like you said,
it's a breaking point,
it's a turning point.
Do you feel -- Do you have
any optimism that anything
will come of this?
-I think the optimism
can be seen in these
young people especially,
the ability to unite
and be on the same accord.
And it's coming across
as extremely destructive,
but I do think
if they channeled it
that they can get a lot done
that generations before them
couldn't get done.
And we're seeing their power.
I think that's optimistic.
But also, you know, now it's --
You know, a lot of times
people come on these shows
and they will speak
for the community.
And this is
one of those rare times
where you don't have to
speak for the community
because the community is
actually speaking for themselves
louder than they ever have.
And so it's really up to them.
It's really up to us
as a community,
but it's really up
to this younger generation
who's tearing stuff apart,
you know?
And, uh...
I hope something good
comes of it.
-I want to talk to you more
about what it's like for a
comedian like you to be living
through self-distancing.
We'll be right back with more
Michael Che right after this.